this video is about transcription in
prokaryotes an overview so in order for
the bacteria to grow and survive
bacteria should produce several enzymes
which would help them in their metabolic
demand and also reproducing and growing
in number so the process by which they
can produce enzyme is called the central
dogma which involves from production of
RNA from DNA and production of protein
from the transcribed RNA so the
important step the important first step
is converting the messages inside the
DNA into a genetic blueprint which is
RNA and this tip is known as
transcription now transcription in
prokaryotes could be seen in three
different phases and the first phase is
initiation second phase is elongation
and the third phase is termination so we
would go about one by one and look at
the details what are the events in each
of these phase let's begin with
initiation
so in initiation the key players are
definitely the DNA's that need to be
transcribed the RNA polymerase and the
Sigma factor so the RNA polymerase and
the Sigma factor forms the RNA
polymerase holoenzyme and definitely the
nucleotide triphosphate which would be
used to synthesize nascent mRNA so just
before the transcription start site the
nomenclature is used as - to denote the
upstream region and the + to denote the
downstream region at n base pair
upstream and 35 base pair upstream there
are some well conserved consensus
sequence
to which the prokaryotic polymerase can
bind and this binding and finding this
promoter is aided by the Sigma factor so
the Sigma factor really helps in binding
of these RNA polymerase to the desired
promoter region now these sequences in
this -10 base pair and minus-35 base
pair are well conserved and these are
known as consensus sequences now after
that it has been seen that without the
Sigma factor the polymerase can hardly
detect the promoter and even if it
detect the promoter and start to
transcribe the gene it would be aborted
after transcribing few nucleotides of
the mRNA so without the pro without the
Sigma factor the fidelity of the
transcription factor transcription is
hampered and the same time promoter
recognition is harder
the most common Sigma factor in the
bacteria is known as Sigma 70 so with
the Sigma factor attached the RNA
polymerase can properly understand which
side to be recognized as a promoter and
it can form the RNA now the most common
Sigma factor is Sigma 70 which bind to
minus 35 base pair tt GAC a region and
minus 10 T 8080 region other Sigma
factors in e.coli involve Sigma 32 or
Sigma 28 for heat-shock chains etc now
the second step is elongation now for
elongation step for the simplicity
purpose this RNA polymerase would be
denoted as a bubble now RNA polymerase
is a big enzyme have having beta - beta
alpha alpha 2 Omega and
Sigma subunit Sigma subunit is part of
the holo enzyme complex the active zone
is comprising beta and beta - of
subunits so in case of elongation this
RNA polymerase introduces positive
supercoiling and the front of it and
leaves the negative super coiled DNA at
the back and inside that inside these
enzyme ntp center that would help to
form the newly synthesized RNA in a
template dependent manner the Strand
which is used as an template is known as
template strand the opposite strand is
known as coding strand now the newly
synthesized RNA has a sequence totally
similar to the coding stat just a
difference is the RNA has uracil whereas
the coding strand has timing so the
sequence in the coding strand is just
similar to the mRNA sequence and the RNA
sequence is complementary to the
template strand now the RNA polymerase
move in a 5 prime to 3 prime direction
and synthesizing the mRNA and RNA
polymerase the fidelity and the
processivity in the RNA polymerase is
lesser than a DNA polymerase because you
can clearly imagine if the DNA
polymerase makes an error then that
error could be detrimental because
replication only happens once but for a
transcription a gene could be
transcribed wire RNA polymerase several
times
so one transcripts if it is faulty it
might give rise to a faulty protein but
that might not be so important in the
long run so that's what that's why the
fidelity of the transcription process or
the accuracy of the transcription
process is way lower than the
replication and the rate of
transcription is roughly 40 nucleotide
per second now if we zoom into the
structural details of the RNA polymerase
in bacteria and all about these
details are well-known due to the x-ray
crystallographic structure we would
clearly see in the beta and beta -
subunit there is the entry site of the
untranscribed DNA that enters and the
helices activity creates the Strand and
separates the Strand and in a magnesium
dependent manner the polymerization
happens now for polymerization to occur
the specific catalysis is known as metal
ion catalysis here the magnesium forms
magnesium is actually used to stabilize
the triphosphate that is getting in
entered as ntps from the ntp entry site
now the templates the the newly
synthesized strand which is
complementary to the template strand
attacks the phosphate linkage using a
nucleophilic attack and as a result the
new template strand is the complementary
strand to the template strand that means
the newly synthesized mRNA is elongated
now definitely there are some antibody
there are some antibiotics such as
rifampicin which blocks this process by
binding to a site adjusting to the
active site and works like a steric
factor of entry to the of the substrate
DNA inside it that is how the activity
of these enzymes could be blocked by
several antibiotics as well
now then we come to the overview of
termination in bacteria the termination
of the transcription depends upon our
termination sequence which is present at
the end of these the transcript now
there are two modes of termination one
is row dependent termination so row is a
helices which can literally move across
the RNA and free the RNA from the hold
of the RNA polymerase and the whole
complex dissociates and the synthesized
RNA is
now free from the DNA and that second
type of termination is known as pseudo
independent termination where it has a
palindromic sequence which forms a
hairpin loop and it prevents the RNA
polymerase to move further forward and
also there is a poly u site poly you
stretch and in poly you stretch the
adenine and uracil bonds a relatively
weak so such that it could be easily
broken and the mRNA could fall out of
the DNA so that was all about overview
of the prokaryotic transcript in other
videos I would be talking about a
eukaryotic transcription and regulation
of prokaryotic transcription stay tuned
and if you like my video give it a quick
thumbs up don't forget to Like share and
subscribe thank you